he connected all of us he was the glue  yeah so who's the glue moving forward  who will who will i'm the gluten  that holds us together it's true so i  was i just ate a loaf of bread over  there before we started the interview so  i feel great it's weird bob still is the  glue like i think we all like feel like  we've got to keep it going keep you know  the relationship strong and i will carry  on the inappropriate torch perfect i  will carry on  the leadership in a danny tanner super  organized in front of everything she's  already charged kind of way and i'm  going to keep up with  the deeply neurotic jewish guy  perfect  i know  bob's feminine oh